ブーブー言っ
は辛い時は辛い this 吐息なんとかも自分の愛すぎてもやばくて
ベストない時はすっごいだけですもうみんな馬鹿丸出し
小学校中学校高校より勉強しない人がもうほとんどじゃないですかね
バカですその中でもきっとコツコツ勉強してる人が将来的に幸せになるかわかんないん
ですけどわかんないですよ僕の
周りだけかもしれないですけどね
僕はその中の一人そんな遊んでないぞバイト末家培土頑張ってるから馬鹿じゃない
馬鹿じゃないええええ
4強の歌手今日のお菓子
今日のお菓子は安定期のその生ドーナツ
いい
名古屋のお店でしたっけすごい美味しいですねもう
これがブルーベリーこれが一応
これがオレンジです
ひゃっほん
ちょっとハゲすぎましたねどうぞによりこの安定して商品が置いてあるんですけど
ハズレがない気がします
基本的に全部 masa です大高級感偏ってますよね
この感じ
なんか五大堂のおいてにもあるかわかんないんですけど僕はローソンで買えました
怖い
1規則一方ん
絶対においしいお
おいっ
だねこれはちょっと待ってやるぞーなんだ切るぜ
今まで紹介した中のお菓子の中で
や誰かのゾーイのように入れて入るよこれ
いやもう一位だ修ん
めっつーめーぞ
なんで説明したらいいかなくっても感覚がないというか
たんだろうなぁフルーチェみたいな感じこれやべえは酒税ずはじめずポイント借銭です
よ
本当にうまいはちょっと土下の説明欄にその蔵品のサイトを載せておきます
やべあ久々に狙う
がいつもね雪は商品紹介するときちょっと守るんですよ
やっぱ美味しいタゲってたらダメだろう
これはね
本当にネ持ってないよ本当に置いする
あーおれんじゃあちょっと甘さ控えめかな15だっ凄い美味しかったどんなつの概念を
遥かに凌駕した感じの
とりあえず夏休みに入りましたのでまぁちょっと日本
できるだけ満喫だと思いますじゃあ
goo ん
me